what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start make sure you like the
video let's get this video to 2,000
likes that is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams also guys if you want to support
the channel get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today if you want
to be the ultimate alpha male that all
the other men really just look up to and
the women just love get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today also guys
our producer for the channel has a
boxing match this weekend in London
England if you guys want a ticket make
sure you DM him on Instagram the link is
going to be in the
description okay so our first story
today is now it's interesting when
relationships end so as you guys may or
may not know Sophie Turner and Joe Jonas
are getting a divorce and the
interesting thing is when these
relationships end what happens is old
clips of these people start to go viral
indicating problems in the relationship
that maybe the public didn't notice
before um so there is a clip right now
going viral of Sophie Turner talking
about Joe Jonas let's bring it up if
you're wearing denim pants at home like
what does that say about you during
you're wearing denim during the
quarantine at home when no one can see
you when no one can see you what does
that say about you as a person like are
you
a psychopath yeah you mean it's not and
Joe does that Joe wears denim trousers
at home when no one can see I'm I'm not
I'm not wearing denim trousers you know
what's interesting being in the position
I'm in I feel like I understand what
it's like to be a guy because the same
way that women will degrade men in
relationships they degrade me for just
talking uh Pearl has a channel and a
Twitter and people like what Pearl says
and then Pearl's the bad guy that people
think the stuff I say makes sense okay
so often times what happens what I what
I find is whenever you say something as
a chick all of the women will come out
and just pick you apart oh Pearl I don't
like your fashion your hair your this
your that you're that you're that and
the list just goes on and on Pearl
you're not this enough Pearl
uh you swear and it just becomes a shoot
the messenger which is why I always say
don't shoot the messenger now when I see
women do in relationships very similar
is they just start nitpicking so this
woman is dating a rich handsome multi-
kajillionaire I mean I don't know how
rich he is but Rich enough right a guy
that is Rich famous and goodlooking and
her big problem let me get this straight
check notes you know her big her big
issue with him is that
he wears jeans during
coid now I'm not saying there were no
other issues in the relationship as you
know you know fame money and Fortune
does not typically equate to a
successful marriage however um I wanted
to point out that men don't find this
funny or cute it is not funny or cute to
make fun of your significant other in
public I and I already can hear the
respon I'm going to get by pointing this
out we have a real problem in society
where we do not have the level of wives
that we used to that really honor and
rever their husbands in public okay so
the next story we have and just like a
trend I see is women having double
standards an example of this is women
will [__] and moan about men going to
clubs in a relationship but feel
perfectly entitled to girls nights with
their group of friends if a man put
himself in a room with a bunch of women
that wanted to sleep with him the woman
would have a field day she would be
pissed however women feel perfectly
entitled to have social media and be
able to go on girls trips in
relationships to show the level of
delusion and narcissism that we have in
this Society I wanted to show you a
video of a woman freaking out about a
man calling his ex but feeling perfectly
entitled to calling her ex let's bring
it up if you call your ex right now and
she answers I'll give you 20 bucks he's
not calling his ex get the [__] out get
the [__] out it's like an easy 20 bucks
no I don't care the easiest 20 bucks you
ever made in your life can I call my ex
sure wait what do I have to call my ex
wait so he can't call his ex but you can
call your ex the answer yeah do I got
his number
still
and the answer
mhm
hello oh sh he answered who's just
here's the 20
hello darkness my old
friend I've come to talk with you again
now how respectful are you of your
boyfriend if really and truly it takes
$20 for you to publicly disrespect him
guys respect is love to men and these
public humiliation rituals for men
really have to go and have to stop
unfortunately we live in a society that
have told men that they just need to put
up with it and told women that this is
perfectly okay and we have women doing
this from an increasingly younger and
younger age and to me it really all
starts in the home again as I've said on
this show before we have a generation of
shitty wives I would argue that we have
not one not two but three generations of
just terrible wives and mothers the
women of yesterday really have led our
generation of women astray the comment
section really does agree with me they
said to the streets she goes Outcast
says that's how you know she run the
relationship homie ain't saying [__] and
it's true simps allow women and reward
women for bad behavior now I wanted to
point out the future of society I don't
say this in a happy way but if I had to
predict what I would see in 50 years
this is what I would
guess marriage and relationships really
are going to go away except for the
upper class the elite do believe will
still marry but I believe it will
continue to disappear in the middle
class the reason being richer men are
able to better fight in court and
they're better able to you know afford a
wife and recover if it goes south now
that's not to say that I haven't seen
rich men get royally screwed over in
divorce court that absolutely has
happened but in my experience it's the
middle class American workers that are
not able to recover so where does that
leave us with all of these single
mothers on the market you are going to
see older women start to live together
so there is an article that I saw I
believe showed me what I think the
future is which I can't even imagine how
bad of a child can you imagine having
Four Women in the same
house four single mothers oh my God and
women it's not like women get together
and become better people it's like we
become worse people so um okay so this
article discusses the Journey of four
single mothers who jointly purchased a
4un apartment building in Washington DC
to build equity and share housing costs
this existing floor plan of the 1927
building presented challenges
particularly for one of the mothers who
needed more space and privacy for her
two kids they hired architect lenal
Schneider to redesign the floor plan
investing $4,000 in renovations to
create a more practical and efficient
layout shinder expertise in compact
Living Spaces and her commitment to
co-housing projects help transform the
apartments into a more suitable living
arrangement for the group they also
considered long-term expansion options
including the possibility of additional
dwelling units to accon to accommodate
the growing needs of the families and
generate extra incomes overall The
Single mother's collaborative approach
to housing and their willingness to
invest in the redesign of their
Apartments to meet their unique needs
showcases the advantages of shared
living arrangements and thoughtful
architectural planning and addressing
modern housing Holly Harper is the
founder of anagram Consulting blue bikes
Communications and siren Foundry she's
also founded a company known as Street
Pearl oh hey look at that look at that
now you're going to see a rise of single
people you're going to see a rise of
couples without children and you're
going to see a rise of single mothers
you are going to see Society reshape for
a post-marriage world and I predict that
you will you will absolutely in fact
start to see single mothers pull their
resources as well as elderly women
coming together pulling their resources
and having houses together now we have a
single mother that is talking about the
experience of being a single mother
let's pull it up know it's crazy because
I um joke a lot about being single
and but I'm 46 years old
and while I'm getting ready for surgery
and
everything it daed on me that I'm 46
years
old and I don't have a husband to take
care of
[Music]
me I don't have a husband
to help me get
ready being single at 46
[Music]
sucks it just
sucks and I'm [__] tired and I make
jokes
about the [__] buffoons that I have
been
encountering in and dating this is my
reality and this those stories are the
[__] that's available because all the
good men have gotten married
in their 20s and 30s cuz they're good
men I'm not blaming it all on men
because women are [__] [__] they
[__] bat [__] crazy too so but um
this is my reality not anybody else's I
wanted to point out her mentality and
the thing is women's words mean
something and they reveal
something so what did she say I don't
have a husband to take care of
me but it's supposed supposed to be the
other way
around I mean the true definition of a
wife is a helpmate you're supposed to
take care of your husband now obviously
obviously it goes both ways but my point
is
typically when you hear women's
reasoning for wanting a husband and it's
a selfish thing it's about them
typically that's the reason why they
haven't been able to get one because
selfish women do not end up getting
husbands they end up dying alone so the
com section said I don't feel sorry for
you you made the bed now lying it um
Lion raw says this is what they wanted
and it's true Al fono don't say that
you're beautiful I'm sure you'll find
the perfect person God has a plan for
everybody no no no no stop saying that
guys like this is why like guys as women
we just need to be sick of this [__]
I am tired of being pandered to no most
women are not going to have a happy
ending feminism has lied to women and
there is an entire generation of women
coping with the fact that most will be
alone in the next 50 years yes yes yes
and most women that woman should not
expect to get a husband ever she can
hope for one if she gets one then
great but I would argue that telling
that woman to make a financial plan of
how she is going to spend the next 50
years of her life is a far better option
than selling the dream that there is a
husband waiting for you at the end of
this that is not the reality for a lot
of women and the issue you get is all of
these influencer women will come out
saying they're so happy single Emily
Rakowski said that but are most women as
attractive as Emily or have the same
Financial opportunities as Emily the
answer is no most women are living
paycheck to paycheck they make about
$35,000 a year and a large majority are
in debt women have so much debt so what
is going to happen to them in their old
age women make poor decisions and keep
expecting men to bail them out but one
day men are going to stop bailing them
out and we are going to see a huge rise
in the number of homeless women po Leaf
Viking are we not better than this
gentleman no one deserves to be
miserable and alone uh look at this just
because this girl made poor decisions in
her youth is no reason for her to
continue to be miserable she's got a
life ahead of her to find her person she
just needs to go find them have some
empathy it's pitiful people might think
I'm mean but I am just not in the
business of selling dreams I won't do it
I refuse like if I don't think something
is likely if I know that the chance a
woman has is if unmarried by
35 actually if a woman is single at 30
not in a relationship she's actually
more likely to not get married than to
get married so at 30 if she has a
boyfriend her odds are a little bit
better but if she doesn't have a
boyfriend because it on because on
average it takes men three years to
marry you so that's something as women
we have to take into account yes on
average it's going to take three years
to convince a guy to marry you so I'm
just not in the business of selling
dreams at 46 it's probably over um I
hope she has savings and what I would do
if I were her is I would figure out a
financial plan on how to live the rest
of my life alone um I would also look
for a husband in the process and see
what they what what you can do but I I'm
just not in the business of selling
dreams and and I think that women are
just Soul a dream over and over again
God's timing it'll happen when really
you have to put effort into making
things happen I'm a I'm a patriarch I
believe in patriarchy I think think that
you shouldn't have rights unless you're
willing to take on the responsibility
that comes with it that's my opinion and
I think until women take on the
responsibility of men that really why is
it fair that we have the same rights so
it's interesting because what we've seen
in instead of going more towards
patriarchy is more egalitarian models so
more fair and more equal but a lot of
times when women are in the man's
position and have to take on the
responsibilities of the then they don't
like it so here is a woman refusing to
pay child support let's pull it up so do
you not think you need to be paying
child support to him no he makes more
money than I do but he has the full
responsibility of parenting the child
you're not doing anything you don't even
want the baby yeah if he wanted the baby
he should take care of it then you made
that up how much money do you make 4,000
a month 4,000 what do you do for a
living I'm an exotic dancer oh okay so
$4,000 I mean you don't want to pay him
correct no that's not how this works
your net calculated at
$3,266 181 which brings your child
support amount to
$653 36 and you cover health insurance
then $44 a month so that amount is going
to be added to that so$
65336 plus the $344 that he pays and
health insurance will be
$997 36 a month he can come back later
he comes back in here you've made more
money you already know what's going to
happen
[Laughter]
right so this woman wants child support
this is what I mean the audacity this
chick he's watching the kid she expects
money women view children as a Payday
yes yes yes yes and I think it's
hilarious that this chick now has to pay
child support if it's up to me I just
think the government needs to get out of
the business of marriage Mar in Family
Court I think you need to leave this up
to the parties yes I actually I think
custody should automatically go to the
dad except for in cases of abuse men
raise far better children than women I
think the idea of Four Women in a house
together raising their their children
single moms is terrible I think that's a
recipe for disaster for the kids and
what did the comments say do they say
lady this is to totally fair no we have
the simp attack he needs to man up and
stop complaining crying and begging no
wonder she left him good on
her wow what a day she's calling her own
child and it he is better off without
her there you know we get we get both
right right right okay yeah and this is
a crazy lady I'm so tired of these crazy
women so as you guys know we have
covered the Dylan danis and Logan Paul
drama Dylan danis is scheduled to fight
Logan Paul on the 14th of October so in
this time period Dylan has posted
multiple pictures of nah a dolls past so
this includes all of these pictures of
nah with all of these different dudes
from the last decade so um what I
noticed today is that Mike actually
posted a picture of his new girlfriend
Logan's best friend Mike now I'd like to
say I don't know who this chick is but
this has to be an upgrade from Lana
rhods you cannot tell me any different
there's nothing that Dylan danis can
post about this chick you know I don't
want to say nothing I mean he proved us
wrong on Nina Agdal I would be surprised
if there was something that he could
post that is worse than what what's out
there about Lana rhods now Dylan danis
has now started attacking Mike's
girlfriend so these are some of the
pictures that he's going um hopefully
this chick doesn't have such a checkered
past you know
um but yeah Dylan has taking no
prisoners so we're actually sending a
team I won't be here but we're actually
sending our talent Christine from the
audacity Network to go film the fight so
you know hopefully this will be this
will be a good fight who are you guys
rooting for let me know in the comments
who do you think I actually I think
Logan's gonna I don't know much about
fighting Logan just looks like he's in
better shape this is just girl girl girl
you know girl analysis but that's my
guess on who will win um but I wonder if
this lawsuit will make him call off the
fight I don't
know okay so I notic okay so I noticed
it's so interesting I go on Twitter and
sometimes I just see these old rants
about me so there's this chick named
Lisa
Elizabeth these chicks these chicks all
right so this girl named Lisa says do
you know why I can't stand Pearl there's
so many women out there like me who have
lived a life that internalized feminism
and didn't even realize it okay so this
is an X I'm just taking notes here I'm
taking taking notes so this is an ex
feminist all right that didn't know
they're out here making changes to their
lives and trying to be good Christlike
moral
women do you see like trying it's not
it's interesting when you really analyze
women's language are they being good
Christlike moral
women or are they trying because there's
there's a
different and she just shits all over
them
receipts receipts please okay Pearl I
just want I want to write down my
complaints I like I like to know I'm
just filing the complaints Pearl
shits on women
all
right if if anything she'll push women
to be more
feminist Pearl
says be a feminist I've never heard that
come out of my mouth but okay okay yes
women today are under the spell of
feminism and don't realize
it you're telling me these only fans
chicks have no idea that that's the
wrong
decision 4% of women are either on only
fans or do cam work that doesn't include
the women that have done sex work on
Instagram and other light forms of sex
work um I would argue it's closer to 10%
and they have zero
idea really Lisa really it's so funny
it's like I'm the one who has I I hardly
doubt in the last two years she's
interviewed 600 plus women and
men yeah they always think they know
know better it's so interesting okay
they have been told to deny their
biological nature well it's not my fault
they do only fans okay they were lied to
told they need to be equal and
independent that being a mother
shouldn't be a priority all to the
detriment of both men and
women
okay you know it's so interesting you
can kind of see how accountable a woman
is by how she analyzes Society you know
it's so interesting because think about
this
who makes the culture who's responsible
for the culture if women have the
authority in most households and there's
more women raising children than men who
is responsible for the culture if women
have been given more freedom than ever
who is responsible for society now you
could argue that it's the simps that let
us do that
but this chick will blame feminism is M
instead of the women and it's
interesting because what you'll see is
women that think like this tend to do
that in their own personal life too
nothing's ever their fault feminism lied
to me and had made me make those choices
it was feminism not me so you know
interesting
okay okay of course women should submit
to their husbands yes true okay but
telling women to blindly submit to any
man no God and no understanding serving
his wife has left many women used oh but
do you see that gosh I just cannot stand
I cannot stand women that will blame
everybody else but themselves women left
women used alone and abused and back to
hating men if if women are in that
situation women did it to themselves no
I'm not going to blame
feminism no no no no I blame choices I I
blame individual choices and what you're
going to notice here is is it's
never my choic has led to this it's well
feminism lied to us now I would actually
more than feminism what I would actually
if I was GNA you know default blame
which I certainly can a little bit I
would actually put it more on because
the mothers did lie to their daughters
the mothers did we have a we do have
like three generations of shitty wives
but you know I could also think of many
women and men that had shitty parents
didn't do the wrong
thing like if your dad tells you to be a
criminal and you choose to be a criminal
I mean are we going to blame the guy or
we gonna blame the
dad okay the notion of submitting to a
man who has no like it's so gosh these
women write paragraphs it's like and
it's so interesting so I'm like aren't
these chicks married don't you have like
a a kid to watch or something all right
it's like imagine I was thinking about
this I'm like like imagine being so
triggered by Pearl that you just write
like a essay about me okay the the
notion of submitting to a man is no
understanding or commitment to church
God and family and serving both your
husband and your wife is the couple is
doomed her message absent of God Is A
Dangerous one and a Surefire way to
accelerate feminism if you ask me she's
a controlled opposition
feminist oh dear here we go okay so let
me let me write down I just wanted to
write down her complaints
controlled
opposition I I don't even know what is
controlled opposition mean what like I
genuinely don't even know what the
like is that mean like is someone
supposed to be paying me because if
someone was paying me that would be
amazing but you know what I mean it's
like okay okay ex feminists have every
right and it is amazing when they switch
their decisions when it only fans woman
or gets off of only fans I Rejoice I say
that is amazing but I do not sell dreams
and tell them that you will have a
happily ever after and a man will bail
you out of that decision men will look
at your record men will look at your
past if a man determines that your
actions in the past do not qualify you
to be a wife a mother and demand a
traditional outcome in marriage it is
what it is I don't shoot the messenger
but a lot but a lot lot of men are going
to look at the market today and say no I
do not want ex feminists and saying this
does not make me mean saying this does
not make me evil and this can be backed
up by data so Morgan Stanley a bank that
has no bare no that is no dog in this
fight is predicting that half of women
are going to be single and
childless now am now am I the bad guy
for pointing this out the the issue is
women like this want men to sign up for
marriage regardless of the fact that
there are no virgin women on the market
only 4% of women are virgins on their
wedding days and let's break down that
4% what percent of that 4% is obese what
percent of that 4% is argumentative what
percent of that 4% was raised to be
wives there is a lack of wives on the
market and the issue is instead of
looking Inward and saying you know what
maybe we just have to improve as women
women will shame men for walking away
and saying oh no I'm not signing up and
then cry and whine to Pearl when Pearl
says oh no oh no oh no don't sign up for
those the the mutual submission
chicks now uh is this [__] on women
I often offer praise to the amazing
wives and mothers out there there are
awesome and amazing wives and mothers
and I could I could point you to many
there are women that I grew up with that
were pH phenomenal there are women that
I know personally my friends that are
awesome wives and mothers that truly
believe in serving and submitting to
their
husbands but do you know what the common
thing you find with those chicks those
chicks know that they are rare and most
of the time those women do not put
themselves on a pedestal and have a
holier than thou attitude so I don't
know what this controlled opposition is
U some people are now saying I'm so
tired of these conspiracy theories
they're they're saying I'm paid by this
person and that person where are my
paychecks please please send me some
money I'm waiting it's like crazy this
is crazy town um
okay the now the last video today guys I
usually do like four or five topics
maybe six this I added as a seventh
topic because I thought this was the
funniest thing that I saw so men in 20
23 especially white men are
discriminated against for jobs diversity
quotas have led to men being
discriminated against and passed over
for high-paying jobs and given to women
one industry I have seen this in is the
tech field I remember being about 22
years old and I was working in copier
sales and I had a woman tell me that she
worked in Tech and that I should get a
tech job because it made about six
figures I made about $45,000 a year at
my sales job and I thought wow what
would I have to do to double my salary
that sounds amazing now this chick told
me about her day-to-day job and really
it seemed easier than what I was doing
and I worked in an all mail space The
Coop copier sales um which is what I
sold is not typically what you want to
do with your free time I'll tell you
that there were not many women that
wanted to sign up for this job it is a
very competitive industry and really
boring to be honest I also worked there
during coid so the entire industry was
on the
decline now I thought to myself wow that
sounds amazing
Tech um I can't even remember what she
did in a day honestly this was so long
ago I just remember thinking that wow
that doesn't seem that hard during it
was interesting because during Co about
a year later this woman got laid off and
I saw thousands of people in the tech
industry get laid off in the next couple
of years um and it it was interesting
because if you looked at Twitter and you
saw before and after photo of of the
Twitter team um when they cut off like
80% of its staff really it was mostly
men that made the cut there were a
couple women that stayed in the company
but it was the exception not the rule I
am always willing to acknowledge and big
up exceptional women but what I am tired
of is them giving stupid women jobs that
they don't deserve now there was a woman
in Tech Career career conference now
again I personally and I don't know the
industry that well so I could be wrong
my guess is there are a lot of useless
jobs in tech for women my reasoning
behind this is really that I keep seeing
all the women get laid off when the
rubber meets the road and they have to
make Cuts now the interesting thing
about feminism and Men is that men will
always find a way around things if you
make the game rigged men will somehow
figure out how to play it now feminists
and often times in these woke tech
companies where these women really
haven't experienced reality because
they're overpaid um you have a lot of
leftist chicks and liberal chicks that
work at these companies the woman I'm
thinking of that I spoke to a couple of
years ago was absolutely a woke
leftist and um so the men decided that
they were going to identify as
nonbinary and apply for these jobs at
this conference let's pull it up career
conference for females in Tech was taken
over by male attendees they were there
just purely for the career fair social
media Clips filmed at the Grace Hopper
the world's largest gathering of women
technologists show men standing in line
to meet with recruiters this is a space
for women in Tech this is one of those
few limited resources that isn't for you
it's for us some of the male attendees
reportedly lied about being nonbinary
just to get in but it's interesting that
the large majority of the people that
actually ended up in the event had name
tags with he him and have no searchable
history of identifying as non-binary
several Tech workers defended the men
for trying to capitalize on job
opportunities not meant for them seeing
that the entire concept was wrong let's
be honest there is no need for a
conference just for women because if it
was the opposite of for men then it
would be sexist just because you are a
woman doesn't give you the right to talk
to a big firm recruiter guys work just
as hard and they don't get that chance I
think this is the funniest thing I've
seen all day yes okay women based women
out there the two women that watch my
show can we please stop can we please
start protesting these freaking women in
business women ower we don't need this
[__] if you are a talented woman in
business you will succeed we don't need
these stupid quotas we don't need these
stupid conferences these stupid handouts
all it does is bring stupid women
together to feel like they're more
important than they are if you deserved
the job you would not need this [__] I
am so TI sorry I am so tired I am so
tired because do you know what it does
the women that actually deserve these
jobs and actually put in the work are
discredited because they give out so
many high-paying jobs to stupid women
idiotic women leftist chicks and
honestly I think it's amazing that these
guys are protesting this um why do why
do women get special privileges to meet
with these recruiters if the resume was
good they would have experience to show
and they would get the jobs and it's
interesting because even the recruiters
will tell you they discriminate against
men for these jobs and then we wonder
why there are more and more young men
that are unemployed well when you're
taking their jobs and giving them to the
women
that's what you're going to see guys and
and it hurts the women that are actually
talented because do you know what
happens people just assume they're there
because of a quota the truth of the
matter is making money as a woman is
easier than ever and I think more men
should protest this stuff I think more
men I think that I think they should
make men's conferences if they're going
to make women's conferences but honestly
dividing it by the genders I think is
stupid just put The Talented smart
people in a room all right Rena says why
am I seeing so many men at Grace Hopper
we can't have
anything well when you think about it
women are the ones that invaded male
spaces first we went into the workforce
we went into the bars we we wanted to do
Sports all of their stuff we invade and
then when they invade our stuff we cry
Autumn says it's [__] that some men
are suddenly fake identifying with she
her pronoun wants to go to Grace Hopper
because they can't find jobs otherwise
at the same time be blatantly oppressing
people genuinely transitioning and and
embracing their gender identity any
woman that is stupid enough to believe
in gender identity I believe should be
banned from all the companies because
honestly if you can convince her that
there is gender identity God only knows
what you will convince her of the Grace
Hopper conference is specifically aimed
at wom intact and there are recruiters
there in order order to push more hiring
of women in these fields it's been
overrun by men buying tickets I hate
these Freaks and I hate women that can't
compete either compete or get out we
don't need these special recruiters
giving us special jobs that we don't
deserve we don't need these special
privileges if you want to be in a man's
world then be in it and stop crying
about it I I encourage the men to buy
more tickets um and get rid of these
stupid conferences so let me know what
you guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and get yourself a women should
have vote t-shirt today none of this
[__] would have happened if women didn't
get the right to vote so like it on your
way out subscribe to the channel and
I'll talk to you next time